parce que comme vous parlez beaucoup le
truc mais comme on mélange comme
effectivement tu mélanges beaucoup de
choses moi je comprends qu'il y a des
parents moi ton enfant vient de voir dis
voilà à l'école il y avait une dame
enfin une dame ou un monsieur avec de la
barbe habillé en princesse il y avait
des parents qui ont pas les mots pour
expliquer les choses aussi des des
parents qui sont complètement
décontenancés par parce que leur dire on
va où les questions que vous posez leurs
enfants
j'ai rien compris moi il y a peut-être
des parents qui vont être mal à l'aise
pour expliquer
je comprends que ça pose problème il y a
des parents qui ont qui ont du mal à
expliquer à leurs enfants ce qu'ils ont
vécu lors de cette lecture mais oui bon
écoutez si vous comprenez rien faites un
effort
j'ai compris personne ne les oblige mais
je comprends pas tu es fou quoi personne
les oblige à y aller je veux dire ce
sont les parents c'est les parents
soient éduquer leurs enfants
différemment qui est une certaine
ouverture d'esprit moi je trouve ça
génial
l'information ou les ou les Willy donc
en l'occurrence personne ne te force à y
aller donc je comprends pas que ça pose
un problème tu décides amener ton enfant
pour
d'expliquer aux enfants
non mais moi je sais pas ce que je sais
pas quel mot je pourrais trouver pour
expliquer à un enfant
arrête et après peut-être vous pouvez
aussi entendre
vous pouvez aussi entendre que des gens
qui soient mal à l'aise devant une
situation comme ça pour longtemps
qu'il y a des gens qui soient j'aimerais
avoir Géraldine Benjamin il est mal à
l'aise parfois sur la tête
j'avais peur de quoi en fait vous avez
ces enfants qui assistent à ses ateliers
qui se suicide qui s'automutile qui
fasse peut-être
vous regardez ces gens on a l'impression
comme des malades ou des pestiférés je
vous assure c'est très choquant
c'est-à-dire que je trouve que malgré
tout et je j'ai bien vu le sondage et
une méthode absolument pas je trouve que
même presque dit 13 % pour le oui ça me
paraît même beaucoup aujourd'hui vu
qu'on est dans une société complètement
réac et limite lgbt-fobe
c'est pas dire ça non c'est une bonne
manière si mais je le signe je persiste
pas pour nous on les adore voyons un
homme de trois ans
tout à l'heure
c'est très bien qu'on dise qu'il faut
respecter qu'on peut être homosexuel
c'est très bien mais les drag queen
c'est un phénomène c'est pas du tout